I've never been to Australia you haven't
I've never been I know so many people
from Australia and I wanted to talk to
you because you're amazing and I'm so
excited for you it's incredible that
you've gotten as far as you have with
your obvious physical disadvantages
unbelievable I was marked by the aliens
I'm not kidding around here I was marked
by alien can we get the camera to zoom
in let me show you
you see you see that right there yes yes
foreign
that is their Mark these these three
marks here are actual coordinates it's a
map of their solar system wow
do you have a pan a magic marker of some
kind
just uh yeah yeah a big thick one would
be good okay now see if you join the
coordinates you start here and you start
joining these coordinates like this
you'll see that it's almost a perfect
triangle okay now if you follow this
side of the triangle up that you will
eventually realize where the location of
the space station is
[Applause]
have you ever made love to a camera
literally to a camera yeah they say uh
no but to a box of film I did yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I blew a load into a box
of stuff one time I thought that was
Wayne Fleming oh yes I am on the Twitter
I like I really like it because you know
you you put a thought on there right and
like six seconds later you you know
you've you've insulted someone in Perth
which is
what the hell is this mate you know it's
fantastic yeah but you can get into
trouble really you can't get into
trouble well all these people are
getting old yeah but you don't I
wouldn't think you have any trouble with
that do you well you know I can't get in
the drive I'm pretty exploratory you
know right yeah I like to take the phone
and get all up in there
oh he does hey
[Applause]
wow
[Laughter]
very good sound familiar
getting into a hot bath
I prefer when they act like they're
getting into a cold bath with me
just going to tuck in talking Frenzy
okay
uh you gotta never get into a tucking
frenzy like you're just like
uncomfortable it's hot out and you just
start tucking a neck thing you know
you're
and suffered what can we do in two hours
in two minutes oh the gym
we can invent a new form of travel
it's working
we could do this
[Laughter]
this Roman show it's the Roman show cool
are you broken excellent
[Laughter]
oh man most comedians are super stupid
yeah yeah you get that I'm not real
superstitious I won't circumnavigate the
globe if a black cat crosses my path so
I can come home in the other direction
or anything like that but I do carry
tuna in the truck I said I can like
Spirit them over and then paint them
white oh I see to get this well
yeah a lot of comics are you know I used
to in the old days when I started out at
yuck yucks right uh I uh I I always get
to laugh yeah
it was just yucks and it expands exactly
yeah it really did yeah franchise itself
um but I remember one night I used to
whistle in the dressing room all the
time right and it's all the other Comics
crazy because they're very superstitious
about that sort of thing and one night
it was raining and there was a comic a
wonderful comic named ludino
well he was following me that night and
uh and I started whistling in the
dressing room and he started getting
upset so I opened up an umbrella as well
danced around whistling and he said you
don't do that man you just don't do it
okay it's one of those rules man like
that and I said ah the heck with it man
I went on stage and I slaughtered I did
the best I've ever done I got a standing
ovation and when I came back off stage
ludinos was standing there with an open
umbrella whistling
okay
but I go up there with the family and I
was up there last winter with my
daughter and my grandson and we were on
the ATVs and ice and snow and we're
flying through the trails and he's on
the back of mine and my daughter's
behind us and he's going fast your
grandfather faster faster and I I turn
and I say hey you know we gotta we gotta
go we gotta slow down your so your mom
can catch up and he says dump the [ __ ]
[Applause]
this is my impression of like the uh the
eighth month
but uh you know so I just like to come
out with things I don't like to mess
around I I want to make a reckoning
right now what do you mean seriously I
don't want any secrets any things are
going to hit me from the side like a
freaking tsunami you know I want I want
to get it out I want to talk to people
and tell them what I'm about what I do
what my habits are okay you know so in
respect to your audience to you Dave
thank you to my fans uh I I just wanted
to say tonight that I have been hanging
around with a lot of hookers
Take a Bow
[Applause]
is that a gang sign have you uh oh like
you don't know what it is
you don't know what that is I have no
idea you don't know Jimmy Fallon doesn't
know David Letterman doesn't know we
don't know all the comics and show
business don't know what this is
right yeah what is it come on Jimmy
seriously the time is up people are hip
to this kind of stuff I I'm here tonight
to blow the lid off it to be The
Whistleblower I'm sick and tired of the
secrets and the lies it is the secret
symbol of the Illuminati and you're a
part of it
and it is the all-mocking tongue
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you know check this uh Jim Carrey is
reported to be making seven million
dollars a picture I don't know where
they got that number Seth I wouldn't
even rehearse for less than nine
uh
then they get into my personal life oh
you can eat that check this out check
this out said to be romantically
involved with Dumb and Dumber co-star
Lauren Holly
now I don't know where they dreamed this
stuff up I mean so we sleep together
four or five times a week does that mean
we're romantically involved of course no
no we're just good friends
sleeping buddies this is the worst one
though this is the worst one of his
competition Kerry says I hope they choke
on their own vomit and leave the good
scripts for me die die die
hurry up and die now that was supposed
to be off the Record
how are your friends you know your
friends handling the success is it hard
on them are they well they've completely
changed really you find a totally it's
not me no no it's definitely not me uh
it's good you know that they've changed
uh basically you know the hardest thing
about it is you can't you can't get
sympathy from anybody you know no matter
what happens some people will not cut me
any slack at all I could say I have I
know you see there there you go yeah
right there you know I could say I could
say I have an inoperable disease I only
have three months to live they go yeah
but you're loaded
get a load of this poor little rich boy
only has three months to live
here
don't ever come back in my church again
it's like really it's okay it's very
difficult
I don't exist I have no needs I don't
need you people
none of it nothing I don't need approval
from anybody right uh I need
um three squares a day yeah
what a catch that was and to drink it in
interesting ways do you see that
chemistry it's a metaphor or uh maybe
this hasn't been your experience but
from my experience and that of many
other men and women in stand-up comedy
they work for years and years and years
literally just making pennies and then
all of a sudden you hit it big and your
paychecks increase enormously yeah and
then is that any kind of pressure any
kind of problem for you do you I I'm I'm
I'm completely all right with that it's
it's just it seems to have uh
I seem to have relaxed into it nicely
now uh
I uh it's a bit of pressure I noticed
that it changes you in little ways like
it's changed the way I laugh at parties
oh really I used to go I used to go
that's really funny you know now I go oh
oh
beautiful
you're set out to be a big person your
world's greatest impersonator
but you're also funny it's Jam [ __ ]
keep that [ __ ] over there
[Applause]
yeah I've been good in fact
if you're
studying what's going on and everything
I guess you could say I'm
Aces Jay really
faces
remember 10.
[Applause]
let's do a little uh Matthew McConaughey
because here are the four uh Matt Damon
was the only one I knew who could come
close on a Matthew McConaughey but you
can come real close with the microphones
is there a secret is there a tip to do
oh no it's real simple Dave
all I got to do is
let go of the illusion that I exist
drive around on my Lincoln
rolling this booger
no no thanks
[Applause]